paulla switching gears the Affordable
Care Act and the health coverage of
millions of Americans could face a major
threat to its future this morning a
federal appeals court in New Orleans
appears ready to rule that a core
provision of Obamacare is
unconstitutional when when could we see
a decision on this well Anthony we don't
know exactly when the appeals court will
rule but it's clear that whichever side
loses this case is almost certain to
appeal to the Supreme Court
now the court had previously ruled that
the Affordable Health Care Act is
constitutional because Congress has the
power to tax people it held that if
people had to pay a penalty for not
buying insurance that was effectively a
tax but in 2017 Congress eliminated the
penalty so now the court will decide if
the rest of the Affordable Health Care
Act is still constitutional in December
a federal judge in Texas ruled that the
law is unconstitutional without the tax
the Trump administration agreed without
ruling and refused to defend the law so
multiple states with democratic
attorneys general and the House of
Representatives stepped in to defend the
law but Anthony if the law is overturned
nearly 20 million people could lose
their health insurance children would no
longer be covered until the age of 26
and it could affect people with
pre-existing conditions all of this of
course sets up a potential Supreme Court
showdown right in the middle of the
20/20 campaign a lot at stake there
Paula Reid thanks